we've got to my left right here from the
Carolina Panthers a man who played in
this game just a couple of years ago
he's a finalist for the Walter Payton
Man of the Year award to be given out on
Saturday due to his incredible works
certainly in the Charlotte community
Carolina Panther tight end Greg Olson
good to see you here to see you so you
sat down I missed this your your your
your guy Khalil argon Khalil announced
yesterday he's got one more year left
he's got one more he's gonna play out
2018 season and call it after 12 years
just like Thomas Davis said on it I'll
note we're now two years ago two of our
guys two of our captains so we got a
little bit of a change coming at the end
of this season so do we know did
Spielberg call up Khalil and say we got
a spot for you next I'm sure the next
call is Odin guys talented mr. USC film
school right pretty cool some of the
stuff he's done he made it he made a
short film that's and the guys the guys
incredible yeah I mean you know you've
you've well you know I go back and forth
about Khalil as a as a film guy cuz he
told me that not this past Star Wars but
the one before it
what the what was it called the the last
force or whatever the heck it was called
a new force not a Star Wars game how I
knew that he told me he goes yeah take
your kids to it and I'm like dude
they're there like eight and five are we
good they lasted ten minutes each I only
lasted ten minutes - he rented out every
year that it comes out he rents out the
entire theater like one whole theater he
dresses up like obi-wan and I mean he
made shirts one year we made the per
baka shirts it was a great fundraiser
and the fans loved it and right he'll do
all it all worked but uh he lives for it
it's the highlight of his year every
December when the new one comes out it's
I mean for the week leading up it's the
talk of the facility is if you're going
to kahlil's kind of a nerd fest does
everyone go not everyone on the team he
probably takes 15 20 guys you rents the
entire theater though so I mean why you
know who makes the cut here who gets the
Turk I mean to make this event
great I think it's open invite starts
with a line then tight ends then
offensive players and then like
hand-selected defensive guys oh wow
Luke's like an honorary offensive player
he comes on our o-line tight end camping
trip because we need somebody to help us
fish and do
manly stuff that we're not good at oh
you guys made that epic camping video
that was whoo that was all Khalil just
right take any crisis taking it straight
from cams video right yeah I mean he had
it side by side frame by frame I mean it
was incredible
he's he's a talent too dude Greg Olson
here on the Rich Eisen show okay man
it's a tight end centric Super Bowl huh
I mean both diamonds it's crucial here
whatwhat do the Eagles do let's break it
down axes nose here what do they do with
Earth's that could create the problems
for the the Patriots on Sunday do you
think I think anytime you're a good
running team anytime you can get into
that RPO stuff you hear so many the
broadcast and everybody talk about that
right that the Eagles do as well as
anybody
the tight end just from his alignment
perspective in just basic formations
he's kind of the guy right you're
reading inside linebackers those are the
guys if they come up on the run fake you
pull it and you throw it if he stays
back so a lot of the times the first the
first option in those are POS is the
tight end is that slot receiver so from
that standpoint schematically they do a
great job but then athletically he can
split the formation he could be the
single side X and run individual routes
he can be to a three-man side a two-man
side in the backfield
you know his athleticism his size what
he can do
movement wives tracking the ball you
know when you have a guy like that you
know you see him you mentioned Kelsey's
come on show guys like that when you
have you want to move around and find
ways to get him involved and I think
Peters Doug Peterson does a great job
with them and then there's Gronk
obviously yep he's just his size the
difference maker I mean you're pretty
big dude yourself sighs you know his
style of play he likes contact he wants
that contact he uses it to his advantage
and then from what they do so much of
the empty stuff so you know you never
know on any given formation where he's
gonna be they do as good a job as
anybody in the league as far as getting
matchups that put Brady back there five
wide two of them could be Beck's could
be four receivers in Gronk you know they
do it at so many different personnel
groupings and then he just looks across
the board and figures out which matchup
you want and a lot of times Gronkowski's
matchup against anybody is a good one
and Brady starts with him well Gronk got
knocked out of the AFC Championship game
Kelsey got knocked out of his game
against the Titans do you think those
hits are dirty Craig yeah I think I
think the letter of the law says that
you can't hit guys in the head and
no you know traditionalists and people
say you're changing the game but what
you know what's the alternative do we
want to see stars of our game get
knocked out you know just you can knock
a guy out break his ribs right go hit
him in the chest that mean you're still
but at the end of day do we want to see
Rob Gronkowski out possibly of the
Superbowl possibly in and out of the
concussion protocol leading up to the
biggest game Travis Kelce having to
leave a playoff game that they end up
losing no those guys are huge parts of
this league huge parts of their team and
to a degree those hits I think are
avoidable some of the hits to the head
when a guy's going to the ground and
you're in a bad position sometimes
things happen but I think trying to take
that out of the game is good for
everybody
well Richard Sherman tweeted out after
Gronk got hit that that the alternative
to the hit was at church who hit him
yeah okay that that the alternative to
the church hit where he hit him was to
go in the knees which we saw against I
think it was against Seattle a couple
years ago when Gronk tours knee up and
he's like what would you rather us do
like that anyway I think I think on
paper and again I think what those
defensive guys have to do playing at
that speed and the target is always
moving you know he could have caught
that ball and lowered and now all of a
sudden I hit to the chest becomes a hit
to the face I get all that I think the
letter of the law I think on paper what
they want to see you do is take your
shoulder your forearm whatever and put
it square into his chest his back his
side his ribs he's hit I think that's
the answer and again sometimes that's
easier said than done how would you
change the catch rule Greg Olson would
you change it I don't mind the catch
rule I I know everyone gets up in arms I
know the Steelers one with James was a
big one it should be a catch though if
you're down if you're if your initial
contact with the ground is your knee
ball is in your hands and you haven't
been contacted yet and then you reach
across the goal line as you maneuver the
ball but still in your hands
he's still going to the ground but so
initial contact was me not not due to
anybody contacted right so I think what
happens is the problem that grey area
what I think the NFL is trying to
accomplish and you could argue whether
they're doing a good job or not I think
what they're trying to argue is so I was
part of what started this to Calvin
Johnson catch was again when I was in
Chicago he jumped up over our guy for
the game-winning touchdown came down put
the ball on the ground and stood up and
they swirled he didn't complete the
catch that star
this whole craze then would Dez Bryant
the whole thing I think what they're
trying to do is they're trying to take
all guesswork for the referees out of
the equation and so they're trying to
say if he's going to the ground upon
catching the ball he must retain
possession through the entire catch
because if not in slow motion everything
looks like a catch and slow motion you
can make an argument for anything so I
think they're trying to take that off
the table if you're you catch it and
you're running and you get hit you go to
the ground after you've been established
as a runner ground can't caused a fumble
right we all play those rules as kids in
the backyard
but if you are not a runner you can't
fumble the ball you have yet to possess
and I think that's what they're trying
to get accomplished whether they can
clean up the letter and clean up the
wording and mix explanations possibly
but to me if I'm interpreting the catch
rule that Calvin Johnson catch is a
catch it's a catch we all know his
intent wasn't that he didn't he didn't
need the ground to maintain possession
yes okay that's a be the Dez Bryant not
a catch would be a catch and fumble to
me because he's such a monster physical
specimen you tube Greg you can make a
catch and take up us an expanse of five
to seven yards with two strides of your
legs then it should be a fumble then it
should be a catch fumble correct that's
to me it was clear going to the ground
nobody was also his knee was down first
without being without with the ball in
his hand and then he moved it across and
he breaks he goes very it gets very gray
so don't touch it you don't think the
rule should be I don't think you touch
it unless you have a better a better
solution and until anyone provides a
more clear simplified version of it yes
I think it's hard to introduce new rules
that are just as or more confusing than
the ones that are trying to improve on
okay before I got let you go in Jerome
Bettis Pro Football Hall of Famer joins
us what are you doing here with the
Microsoft create change program sir so
this year we teamed up with them the
create change was a way that they could
lend their platform to help players who
are very passionate about their causes
you mentioned the Walter Payton Man of
the Year my wife and I started after our
son TJ is undergone a very complex heart
condition and subsequent care and we
started what's called the hardest yard
program and we send private Duty nurses
and therapists into the homes of cardiac
families upon discharge to
to increase their care increased the
transition into the home and now because
of Microsoft in this program we're able
to send these nurses in with surfaces
with a custom software cloud program
that integrates directly with our
doctors at Levine Children's Hospital so
when these doc when I brought the kids
home
we brought CGA home we did everything in
a journal maybe two weeks later you'd go
visit the cardiologist now you input all
their vital statistics all their all
their readings and it immediately gets
sent to the cloud the doctor can see it
in real time it's been it's been a game
changer for us and for our heart
families well and again for your
foundation you can go to receptions for
research org and you know you want talk
about a packed field Walter Payton Man
of the Year award you Benjamin Watson
and JJ Watt you know that's a great
honor
thank you you deserve it thank you
really really [ __ ] that's a Greg Olson
follow them on Twitter as I do at Greg
with 1g Olson 88 the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience